你已经建立并被认为是最擅长打造顶级高人才密度团队的人。我们先从人们常犯的错误说起，你称之为“厄运漏斗”的东西。
>> 公司把招聘想成一个漏斗。我打算联系100个人，其中20%会申请。按照定义，那不是最顶尖的20%。那只是你碰巧遇到的那20个人，可能某天他们心情不好。我们的招聘方式是，
在每个阶段淘汰一些人，然后雇佣剩下的人。在你看来，还行。世界上有50个人能做这事。我们去找那50个人，你坚持不懈地追求，把精力集中在激活这些人身上，
而不是试图把他们从“厄运漏斗”里捞出来。大多数公司犯的错误是，他们会说：“嘿，Lenny，你认识的最好的产品工程师是谁？”这是你问得最糟糕的问题。
更好的问题是：“嘿，Lenny，在你合作过的所有产品工程师中，谁是你认为与设计师合作最默契的人？[音乐]或者谁能比你见过的任何人都更好地将框架转化为产品？”
你亲眼见过的那种人？
>> 当你寻找第一位招聘人员时，你觉得有什么重要特质需要关注？
>> 招聘人员在90%到110%的工作量下表现最佳[音乐]，超出这个范围就很糟糕。如果他们只承担一半的招聘任务，他们就有点没用。但他们非常擅长在那种肾上腺素激增的忙碌状态下工作。你要找的就是这种人。
对，找的就是他们。
>> 关于打造卓越团队和让员工长期为你工作，你学到了哪些经验？
>> 当你查看候选人满意度分数时，第一位的因素总是……
>> 今天的嘉宾是Adam Ward。Adam在硅谷以最擅长打造精英高人才密度团队的招聘领导者而闻名。他与人共同创立了一家独立招聘公司Growth by Design，
Cursor于去年全资收购了这家公司，这种事不常听到，这证明了他和团队的卓越能力，也凸显了当今市场上人才的重要性。Adam现在是Cursor的人才负责人，
帮助他们扩展并打造世界上人才密度最高的团队之一。在创办自己的公司之前，Adam在Pinterest领导全球招聘，将公司从200人扩展到超过2000名员工。
在此之前，他在Facebook领导一个由65名招聘人员组成的全球团队，分布在10个办公室，帮助Facebook的技术组织从1000人扩展到超过10000名员工。如果招聘最优秀的人才是你的首要任务（应该如此），这期对话将
开阔你的眼界，让你知道如何做到。Adam会给出非常实战和具体的建议，而且
[音乐]
>> 你会感谢我邀请了Adam来分享所有这些宝贵的建议。[音乐]非常感谢Bree Wolfson、Janet Fishberg、Jill Macre、[音乐]Mike Joiner和Tim Kendall为这次对话提出的主题和问题。
在我们开始之前，别忘了访问lennysproductpast.com[音乐]，可以免费获得一年世界上最热门、设计最精美的AI产品，[音乐]仅限Lenny的新闻通讯订阅者。这样，
接下来，让我们有请Adam Ward。Adam，非常感谢你能来。欢迎来到播客。
>> 非常感谢邀请我，这是我的荣幸。
>> 你做这一行已经20年了，招聘、招募、组建团队。你觉得今天的市场有多么不同？现在的招聘市场有多疯狂？
>> 如果有个衡量标准，那就是11分。但是，你知道，我觉得与过去经历的一些市场有相似之处。你提到那些年月，比如有一段时间很多公司转向移动端。
那时真的没有移动工程师，iOS工程师根本不存在。所以大家都在争抢人才来开发移动应用等等。
就像那时候突然出现了这种需求，与那个市场和时期有一些相似之处。我觉得这里的真正区别是，一切都如此紧凑。所以，那个移动时代是
两年前吧，你知道，当时还没有移动端工程师，然后一下子冒出来一堆移动端训练营之类的东西。如今我们以天、以周来计算变化，几个月甚至几年的衡量标准已经不存在了。
现在衡量周期变成了周甚至天，不再是月或年。所以，这感觉确实非常不一样。
这个市场还有个非常不同的地方：很多人做得极为出色，同时，正如你所说，特定岗位的竞争激烈程度是11分（满分10分）。但另一边，也有很多人处境艰难，
找工作非常困难。
确实，这是两个世界。你能读到连篇累牍的新闻，一边是给应届博士开出NBA级别薪酬的offer，紧接着另一边是蓝筹公司裁员10%。这两件事怎么会同时发生？
你会看到公司开展工作和完成工作方式的转变。我真的相信，我们正处于一个人才、劳动力以及工作方式重新洗牌的时期。而且我坚信，
会有重新洗牌，会有转变，情况最终会恢复平衡，但我觉得现在正是这两个世界差距最大的时候之一，我相信并且愿意相信差距会
逐渐缩小并最终回归接近。
本集节目由本季赞助商WorkOS呈献。OpenAI、Anthropic、Cursor、Replit、Sierra、Clay以及数百家成功的公司，它们有什么共同点？它们都由WorkOS驱动。
如果你正在为企业构建产品，你可能体会过集成单点登录、SCIM、RBAC、审计日志等大型公司所需功能的痛苦。WorkOS将这些阻碍交易的难题转化为即插即用的API，其现代开发者平台专门为B2B SaaS打造。
说实话，我所投资的每一家开始向高端市场扩张的初创公司，最终都会采用WorkOS。因为他们是最好的。无论你是试图赢得第一个企业客户的种子轮初创公司，
还是正在全球扩张的独角兽公司，WorkOS都是让你快速做好企业就绪准备、释放增长潜力的最快途径。它本质上就是企业级功能的Stripe。访问workos.com开始使用，或者直接加入他们的Slack频道，
那里有真正的工程师等待解答你的问题。WorkOS通过令人愉悦的API、全面的文档和流畅的开发者体验，让你能更快地构建。今天就去workos.com，让你的应用做好企业就绪准备。
目前哪些职位需求上升最快、最热门？哪些职位需求又在减少？你有着非常独特的视角，因为你不仅在Cursor工作，之前还经营过自己的独立机构，与众多不同的公司合作。所以你见识过很多不同的地方。那么，哪些职位的需求正在上升？哪些需求最旺盛？哪些又有所减弱？
你之前也有独立的机构，和大量不同的公司合作过，所以你能看到很多不同地方的情况。那么哪些在上升？哪些需求最大？哪些现在可能比较疲软？
嗯，我认为一个真正需求旺盛的角色，有很多不同的叫法，就是这种“前置部署工程师”。这是一种技术人员，能够与销售团队和客户合作，部署可能对某些受众来说技术性很强、甚至令人望而生畏的产品，
或者帮助公司考虑从“token最大化”转向“优化最大化”。随着首席财务官开始看到账单，我认为这是一种新技能。能帮助客户思考最佳解决方案的公司会很受欢迎。这确实是一种独特的技能，因为
随着CFO们开始看到账单，这变成了一项新技能，那些能帮助客户思考最佳解决方案的公司会很有价值。所以，这确实是一项独特的技能，因为你既要
自身技术深厚，理解产品，还要能与高管和领导者们从容交流，协助梳理问题，甚至帮助他们将其部署到员工队伍中。
我认为这是目前一个真正的供需问题。另外，我认为需求正在减弱的可能是专业技术人员。你看，几乎可以看到工程师、产品和设计在某些方面正在融合。
我们希望设计师能成为更偏向设计工程师，希望超级资深的技术工程师有更强的产品意识。所以，
你会发现，那些非常狭窄、非常深入、过度专业化的角色需求在减弱。同样，应届毕业生可能也缺乏经验，
无法胜任那些工作，因为像Cursor这样的产品或者其他工具现在就能做部分工作。
这非常有趣，我以前没听过这种说法。有趣的是，FDE这个角色很像你之前提到的移动端工程师的例子——真正做过前期部署工程师的人很少。
那么，什么样的人能成为FDE呢？
是的，我确实认为，那种工程师，那种可能在三到五年前是全栈工程师的人，现在可能真的变成了那种前向部署工程师，对吧？所以，你去和这些人聊聊
他们会告诉你，这真的能激发他们内心的某些东西。就像是他们走出了终端，走进了公司内部，走进了客户和用户的世界。对合适的人来说，这
超级提神醒脑，为他们的职业生涯开启了新的篇章，或者说是意料之外的一章。
这很有意思。我原本以为你会提到AI研究员，因为这岗位确实不多。
我想是的。这群体非常明确，定义清晰。
嗯。
所以，你可以清楚地看到这类人才的范围、数量和分布。而我觉得，有时候更大的挑战往往来自那些模糊不清的，或者非常新颖的岗位，
这些角色有时候和稀缺的AI或ML工程师一样具有挑战性。
沿着这个思路，我再问最后一个问题：核心产品设计与工程类的角色又怎么样呢？它们是保持稳定，还是某个方向在增加或减少？目前情况如何？
我认为这类岗位依然重要。不过，你可能也注意到网上有很多讨论，我觉得我们正在回归到工匠精神，这是好事。想想看，
AI在设计领域能做什么？它也可能制造出大量劣质内容。所以，我是个乐观主义者，你大概能从我整个谈话中感受到这点。
我也是这么想的。
并且，我认为这是一种更好的生活方式。但是，我希望它能够帮助我们回归到工作的本质，真正去欣赏我们所做的事情。在设计中我也看到了这一点。
那么，这是不是说，个人贡献者更受欢迎，尤其是那些有品味、有判断力的个人贡献者？这是核心吗？
是的，我认为，你看，在过去大约12个月里，我们看到个人贡献者的崛起，以及对他们工作的认可和赞赏，这几乎是一个轮回。但我觉得，品味、决策能力、解决问题的能力，这些特质，以及好奇心，
嗯。
嗯，以及对这些工作的认可和赞赏，我觉得几乎已经到了一个完整的循环。但我想说的是，品味、决策能力、解决问题的能力，这些特质，还有好奇心，
这些好的品质，我觉得正在重新浮出水面。
太好了。好了，让我从更宏观的角度来框定我们这次对话的主题。你构建过并且以能够打造最精英、人才密度极高的团队而闻名。很多人跟我说，你是这方面最强的。这是每个公司和创始人的梦想：打造最高人才密度的团队。所以，我将按顺序探讨。我们首先聊聊你称之为
末日漏斗的招聘方法。请讲讲这个末日漏斗，它到底是什么？
末日漏斗？它是怎么一回事？
好的。这个概念，我得承认，是我在1998年第一次实习时接触到的，当时在一家名为Trilogy的公司，这家公司在招聘方面有点臭名昭著，而那也是我学习这门手艺的地方。
我的第一位经理Jeff Daniel，我们一起在全国各地的大学校园巡回宣讲，接触计算机专业学生，正是在那里我第一次听到这个术语。是他创造了这个说法，我必须承认这一点。但我觉得，漏斗这个概念
几乎永远都是这样，回顾招聘历史，公司们往往把招聘看作一个漏斗，类似销售漏斗。他们会考虑不同的阶段、转化率等等。
当你回顾过去几十年大多数公司的招聘方式，其实候选人主要来自三个渠道：主动申请、被动激活（比如猎头挖角），或者内部推荐。
但如果你稍微琢磨一下就会发现，很多公司在考虑人才密度时，通常重点放在内推、寻源，或者激活被动人才上。再进一步缩小范围，说到寻源这块儿，
大多数公司都是这么想的：我联系100个人，大概20个人会回复，就算20%的回复率吧。但严格来说，这20个人未必是顶尖的20%，只是刚好赶上他们不顺心的时候。
对他们来说，你联系他们那天可能心情不好，对你来说却是好日子。所以从一开始，你接触的就是一群不太理想的人选，并不是最顶尖的那20%。即便你有好流程，后续招聘也是在各阶段淘汰人，最后雇佣剩下的。
所以，这种“捡剩儿”的招聘其实就是漏斗末尾的产物。你仔细想想，这其实挺糟糕的。如果我要长期打造一个高人才密度的团队，这真的是最佳方法吗？还是说，
假设我的面试流程和细节都做得很好，这样长期下来，团队素质是不是也就略高于平均水平？随着招聘量增大，你的水准会逐渐回归平均。所以我们换了个思路：
如果一开始就锁定那顶尖的20%的人选，然后用评估流程去验证这个判断，是不是更好？所以，虽然存在所谓的“死亡漏斗”，但在漏斗里也可以有“卓越支柱”。
想象一下，如果我们从“卓越支柱”出发，而不是什么都靠广撒网式的漏斗，那会怎样？因为“捡剩儿”式招聘成本高昂，而且你实际上招到的是那种被淘汰到最底层的人。
雇佣的是在漏斗中沉淀下来的那些人。
>> 我很喜欢这个观点，尤其是听你这么一说。一直以来招聘都是这个套路，但听你这么一描述，显然这不是最优解。为什么这么多年都没变过呢？
>> 将招聘比作销售漏斗其实是有害的。因为在销售中，销售员通常卖的是标准化的产品，比如软件或物品，这些东西相对固定且理性。但在招聘中，
你面对的是招聘经理和招聘专员这样的非理性单元，以及候选人这一理性单元。所以，如果认为招聘过程像销售一样可以线性、机械地推进，那就大错特错了。
这其实是个谬误。销售已经存在数百年了，而招聘作为一门专业，可能才四五十年。所以在这方面我们还很落后。但作为人类，我们
我们经常会把一个问题和另一个已知的问题联系起来。所以，我认为这种与销售的关联性，实际上对公司来说，在考虑以更具战略性的方式做事时，是有害的。
>> 那么，我们顺着这个思路，把您描述的内容弄得更清楚一些。我听您说过，您把每一次招聘都当作高管级别的招聘，目标是找到全球前1%的人才，而不是那种随便投简历进来的人。请再多谈谈这种思维方式。
而不是那种随便投简历进来的人。请再多谈谈这种思维方式。
>> 如果您曾经做过高级专家或领导岗位的招聘，并且做得很好，那大概有三个主要步骤。第一是定义范围。如果您想找前1%的人才，最重要的步骤就是非常明确地对您来说1%意味着什么。
非常明确地对您来说1%意味着什么。如果您听过类似的说法：“我一看就知道，我一眼就能看出什么是优秀”，实际上您不知道。您不会知道，因为您没有花时间客观地去定义优秀是什么样。
因为您没有花时间客观地去定义优秀是什么样。所以，当我们谈到定义范围，如果我们能深入探讨核心部分，好的范围定义是要思考您要找的技能和经验，然后对这些进行排序。
您要客观地搞清楚这些，在接触任何候选人之前就要明确，但这会影响你的整个流程。它决定了你的寻源策略，也决定了你对候选人如何宣传，因为你会问这样的问题：“为什么这个职位重要？成功是什么样子？”它确实帮助你制定这些。
它确实帮助你制定这些。它也帮助你建立评估流程，明确你要评估什么。它帮助你思考收尾，比如“为什么是这个人和这个职位能在这里产生大影响？”所以，我认为招聘流程中的这一部分投入不足。但在领导层招聘中，这通常被认为是一个非常坚实的基石。
它帮助你思考收尾，比如“为什么是这个人和这个职位能在这里产生大影响？”所以，我认为招聘流程中的这一部分投入不足。但在领导层招聘中，这通常被认为是一个非常坚实的基石。
所以，假设你有非常好的岗位定义，然后你结合非常好的市场映射、情报和信号，这些能让你确信谁是最顶尖的人。
比如做领导层招聘时，你心想：“好吧，这个世界上能胜任这个职位的人大概有50个，我们去找到这50个人。”对吧？所以这种思路，我认为如果你做了很好的岗位定义，并清楚他们是什么样，你可以大规模地这样做。
然后你拿着这份50人的名单，这些目标，你坚持不懈地追求，把精力集中在激活这些人上，而不是从“死亡漏斗”里捞人。
你不是试图从大量人群中筛选。而是精准出击，把精力集中在激活这些人上，而不是试图从“死亡漏斗”里找人。
哇，真是精彩。我猜所有听到这期节目的人都会想：‘我们得赶紧把Adam招进我们团队。’
可惜你现在有本职工作，所以我们尽量多挖点干货。你刚才讲的三步法，从高管招聘的角度看怎么招人，这种思路很值得借鉴。
目标是顶尖1%的人才。第一步，明确顶尖长什么样。就像你刚说的，明确所需技能并排序，列出我们需要的技能，这个人必须具备哪些经验，也排个序。
还要讲清楚这个职位为什么重要，为什么这么关键。除此之外，还有什么要补充的吗？
对，这些是通用框架。每家公司还会有其他特别重要的具体点。但基本上就是这些。记住，这些不是问他们来自哪家公司，而是客观、可迁移的特质。
问你“他们来自哪家公司？”这些是客观、有一定可转移性的。而不是去套别人的流程或对优秀的定义。因为刚才说了，几乎每家公司都搞错了，或者搞成了‘死亡漏斗’。
既然我们自己都觉得别人的流程可能不完美，那为什么还要照搬呢？而且你的公司、你的产品都不同，所以你应该为自己去定义什么才是优秀。
对于这个职位、这个产品，什么样的人能成功，而不是看别人在某个流程里成功过，而那流程你本来就不太信服。
所以你的意思是，别盯着简历上的公司标志，那是个坑。
确实。
嗯。
当然，有些公司确实有高光时刻，比如那家公司那支团队当时做得很棒，也许那个人当时在那个团队里确实厉害，但只是可能罢了。
这可以作为一个快速参考，但大多数公司几乎立刻就跳到这个结论了。
太棒了。那第二步，绘制并找到前50名候选人。有什么工具能帮你？像LinkedIn吗？还是别的？
我觉得是结合多种方式。我们通常从一群我们信任的、品味高的人入手。但这里有个常见的错误，虽然看起来显而易见。
大多数公司会问：‘嘿，Lenny，你认识的最好的产品工程师是谁？’那是最糟的问题。更好的问法是：‘嘿，Lenny，在你共事过的所有产品工程师中，谁是最擅长和设计师合作的？或者谁最能把框架转化为产品？’
你需要把具体的特点、技能或团队需求嵌入问题，这样对方更容易想到具体的人，而不是泛泛地问谁最好。
把非常具体的特点或需求说出来，比宽泛地问‘谁最牛’更容易让对方想起人选。
我想这和第一步是呼应的，那里你列出了技能、经验等要求。
你问的问题正是基于第一步所做的基石工作。所以当你有针对性地向一群人提问时，你会发现他们提到同一批人，像三角定位一样。
嗯。
比如：‘啊，’
呃，
Lenny提过这个人，Sally也提过，我们把他列入候选名单吧。
所以策略的一部分是和信任的、品味可靠的人聊，问他们这些问题。那还有哪些方法可以找到这些人呢？
那么，如果咱们仔细琢磨一下，可以把我们想要的人才特征列出来。比如，我们希望这个人有好奇心，会系统性思考，等等。可能就两三个特点。
接下来，你可能会想，哪些公司在招聘时也看重这些特质？你甚至可以通过简单的布尔搜索或用AI筛选，看看这100家公司的所有职位里，哪些也明确提到了这些特征。
这样，你就能想到，也许这些候选人之前就在那些同样看重这些特质的公司里获得了相关技能。然后，你开始创建一些不常见的公司列表，虽然这些公司可能也在常规列表里，但我们得用事先定好的客观标准来验证。
有意思，在我的最近四期播客中，都提到了系统性思维。这似乎是当下大家很看重的一个素质。
是的，我觉得这个特质其实一直存在，只是在这个时代变得格外突出。
当人们听到“系统性思维”这个词时，你怎么描述它实际的含义？
我在工作的第二家公司时，很早就学到了这一点。这涉及到我们试图解决的根本问题是什么。所以每当我思考系统性思维时，我就会问自己，我们要解决的根本问题是什么？
然后，我们如何把这个大问题拆解成小块？很幸运，我大部分时间都在和工程师共事，我真的很钦佩他们能把一个大的问题拆解开来，逐步解决。只要始终锚定我们最终要解决的整体目标。
很棒，很有帮助。大家经常听到这些词，然后就说，对，我很擅长系统性思维。所以，听听不同的人解释这些词的实际含义总是有帮助的。
我觉得系统性思维听起来很战略，但实际上我觉得它极其战术。最优秀的系统性思考者会把事情转化为非常具体的战术，然后一步步移除障碍，解决每个问题。
所以，回到这个寻找优秀人才的话题上，我听到的大多是坐着聊天，和人们交流，然后在文档里记录推荐的人和公司。
是的，工具有很多，比如LinkedIn之类的。但我觉得最有价值的也是最耗时的，就是你花时间去挖掘人脉网络。
我之前也说过，在我的团队中，有些人专门负责挖掘现有员工的人脉。你可以用AI工具自动化，或者有人工引导，但都比不上我们俩每隔一周坐下来，花六周时间去深入了解候选人。
比如，上次你给了我三个名字，我查了查。那这个人怎么样？你就可以说，哦，这个也很厉害。然后我问，那接下来会发生什么？就这样一来二去。
比如，上次你给了我三个名字，我查了查。那这个人怎么样？你就可以说，哦，这个也很厉害。然后我问，那接下来会发生什么？就这样一来二去。同时，我也会督促你发跟进邮件，看他们回复了吗？如果回复了，你会再发一封吗？
这种一对一、手把手地培养信标的过程，我觉得非常重要。当然，这些信号会录入系统和数据库，但提取的过程我认为是非常个人化和有效的方法。
这听起来非常耗时耗力，那么你怎么看待这种方式的权衡？毕竟大多数公司不会这么招人，不会把每个人都当作高管来对待，毕竟他们只是工程师、产品经理。
你知道这需要更多的时间精力，你如何解释这种取舍？
我通常会问创始人，在所有重要的事情中，人才排在第几位？他们会说，第一。人才是最重要的。那好，如果人才是第一位，那就不是时间或成本的问题，而是应该集中精力在这里。
既然你说了人才第一，那么在努力、资源或时间上就不应该有障碍，因为那对你的成功至关重要。既然你这么说，这两者就不能矛盾。
如果你说人才最重要，然后又说要节省时间成本，那就不一致了。你需要投入相应的努力和资源，确保能找到最优秀的人才。
外包出去，或者交给招聘机构来处理。如果这是最重要的事，那你就得专注于此。
>> 听上去显然是对的。为什么不做呢？然后就像，哦，天哪，到处都是火烧眉毛的事。我得腾出时间处理这些事，这些会议，简直没完没了。你有没有什么办法
帮创始人和团队保持正轨，坚持这个计划，因为知道这需要付出很多时间和精力？
>> 是的，我的意思是，通常创始人会让公司保持在正轨上，最优秀的公司也是这样。而保持正轨的一部分就是让它始终是优先事项。你知道，有句老话说，能衡量的事情才能完成。
所以如果这是一件重要的事，我们就会去衡量它，就像我们可能衡量运行时间、客户满意度或收入一样，我们会让团队对这些负责。我们也会让招聘经理和领导者
和组织对招聘负责。因此，让它始终是优先事项，同时建立正确的奖励和认可机制，所有这些都能帮助人们将其视为优先事项。但如果你不
衡量它，或者他们会将其移交，或者他们会把责任推卸到别处。
>> 是的，你最讨厌的事情之一是让招聘人员坐在那里，基本上是让招聘人员和招聘经理不能深度参与招聘过程。
>> 是的，我认为很多公司让招聘部门负责招聘目标。但我还没见过哪家公司是由招聘人员来做招聘决定的。所以这两者是冲突的。招聘经理、领导者或委员会才是做招聘决定的人。
我觉得招聘人员的目标实际上是帮助提供信心，让招聘经理做出正确的决定。他们是信心的引擎，而不是决策的引擎。因此，我看到很多公司
嗯，他们失去头绪的时候，基本上就是把招聘的功能、招聘的行为，交给了一个招聘职能部门。对吧？所以没有人比招聘经理那个团队更在乎一次招聘，没有人会因为好的招聘或坏的招聘而获得喜悦或痛苦
既然如此，为什么招聘人员或招聘组织要承担这个责任呢？他们实际上没有决策权，更不用说从好招聘或坏招聘中获得的好处、痛苦或成本了。
回到刚才的话题，这其实有点像另一个漏斗，但我先把它叫漏斗吧。你会不会也把它看作一个漏斗，或者说非dooms的漏斗，还是别的什么词，因为它本质上也算一种漏斗？
对，对，不是所有漏斗都不好，其实都挺好的。
人才密度。
没错。
回到如何发掘顶尖人才的话题。幸运的是，有一篇关于Coda如何招聘的精彩文章，作者是Brie Wolfson，对我准备这次演讲帮助很大。
她分享了Coda寻找优秀人才的一个方法：他们有一个Slack频道叫“招聘点子”，团队成员会在这里分享说“这个人我们可能想招”。
这个频道特别活跃。你可以想象，我们现在就能打开看看。里面有人提出想招某个人，然后大家就开始讨论。也许我们可以听听现场观众的意见。总的来说，就是有人
会偶然发现某个令人印象深刻的东西，比如一个产品、一篇文章，或者在烧烤时听到的某个人，然后他们就把那个人的简介或X上的帖子丢进招聘频道，这会引发一种集体关注的效果，大家会说“哦，我听说过他们”，或者“我知道该怎么吸引他们”，几乎就像迅速制定一个如何接触这个人的策略。
想想看，如果在一家这样的公司工作，整个公司都是这种文化，大家都兴奋、热情，喜欢狩猎的刺激感，都愿意和优秀的人共事，那该多好。所以，我们很幸运能有这种持续的动力。
这就像一种早期的期望，一种——我几乎要说，这就像公司里的社交信誉，能够发掘出优秀的人，然后大家都会来帮忙，努力把他们引进公司。
所以，当我们在创建这样的机制时——这样说好了，我们并不是发起者，不会丢个简历问“有人认识这个人吗？”而是公司里非招聘岗位的员工提出点子，然后整个公司都响应的过程。
这太棒了，我们不是发起者，我们是公司里的非招聘人员提出点子，然后大家积极响应的。
太棒了。所以，如果我们再退一步看，大多数公司招聘的方式是这样的：人们申请职位，或被推荐，然后他们经过筛选，你还会主动联系一些人，再经过筛选，最后选出少数几个人。
在底部的那些人，你的意思是，他们不是最顶尖的人才，因为他们不会主动来找你，也不会通过你的筛选流程。很多时候你甚至不清楚自己到底在招什么样的人。
>> 没错，对，对。不过你要知道，有时候这些招聘想法也不一定都是好主意，不一定适合我们，但它就像是给招聘流程注入的一剂偏方，往往能带来
嗯，一个很好的结果。
>> 所以，为了让大家更清楚这种方法的与众不同，它其实是反过来的：先找出全世界最适合这个岗位的前50名人才，然后坚持不懈地去追求他们。
>> 嗯，是的。
>> 那我们来聊聊这部分吧。具体怎么做到不遗余力地去追求这些人呢？你有什么策略或者故事，能说服这些顶尖人才愿意和你聊，甚至最终加入？
>> 嗯，对。我觉得你几分钟前提到过，这可能会是一个很慢的过程。没错吧？如果你是从零开始，第一天，那确实会觉得很慢，感觉像是一种缓慢的
燃烧。但想象一下，在几天的时间里，你实际上是在为潜在的顶尖50人播下种子，他们会在不同的时间成熟。但你必须先播种，必须开始行动。因为对有些人来说，可能需要几周，
对另一些人来说，可能是几个月。我甚至有过花一年时间跟进候选人的故事。但你必须开始计算时间。所以我们如何看待这种不懈的追求呢？你经常会接触到，
第一步就是让他们愿意对话，得到回应，获得某种形式的互动。但大多数人会告诉你，如果你联系他们，他们可能会说现在不是好时机，各种理由说自己无法加入。然后你会说：“嘿，我不是
要求你来面试，也不是让你考虑职位。我只是想约下一次的对话。”所以当你说：“嘿，现在对我来说真的不合适，可能要到深秋吧。”你会说：“嘿，
那太好了，我完全理解。不过，你能过来喝杯咖啡，看看我们的办公室吗？或者，我能介绍我们团队里另一位对你的工作非常感兴趣的人给你吗？
你可以和他聊聊吗？”所以你看，就算你说的是真的，他们要到深秋才能加入，那也不代表你不能现在就开始联系他们，每周都聊一聊，推进关系。这样做只会让事情
往好的方向发展。如果你什么都不做，等到深秋再联系，那最好的情况也就是他们还有兴趣，或者可能已经被别的公司挖走了。所以我们采用持续触达的方法，让他们
进入流程。嗯，但这可能需要几天、几周、几个月，甚至几年的时间。
>> 当你联系某人，提到你在Cursor工作时，现在它已经是SpaceX的一部分了。对方可能会觉得：“哦，这挺有意思的，很酷。”然后，你知道，他们可能会想：“说不准，也许有一天会有机会。”但很多公司，
你也和那些品牌没那么吸引人、也没那么成功的公司合作过。对于那些想让别人愿意和你聊聊的公司，你有什么建议吗？我觉得这可能非常具体，
有什么建议吗？
>> 对，我觉得关键在于前期要花很多时间去了解什么能吸引他们。可能是某个人，可能是某个话题。所以，世界上有很多优秀的人可能
不在任何社交平台上，没有关于他们的信息。但大多数人你都能找到一些蛛丝马迹。我们会花很多时间思考，谁能帮我们做一次温暖的介绍。实际上，我们在这一点上花的心思几乎和写邮件本身一样多。
因为如果你找对了介绍人，那就能加速整个过程。一旦某人忽略了一次你的联系，他们很容易忽略第二次、第三次。但如果第一次就对了，你就能压缩
激活的时间和精力。
>> 我听说你经常说“关心是免费的”。
>> 是的。
>> 说说这个吧，感觉它贯穿了整个流程。
是的，我觉得存在各种不同成本的策略。但在建立招聘团队时，我们总是强调要更关心候选人。这是我们能做到的。
我们可以比任何人更关心那位候选人。这源于我们的内心。而纵观历史，当你看候选人满意度分数时，排在第一位的总是
公司确实想要我。他们让我感觉我属于那里。所以，我们越是关心候选人并表现出这一点，我认为这就是一种不公平的优势，而且我们都有能力做到。
所以这需要付出努力，多走一步。这是你额外投入的心思。我认为，在某种程度上像招聘这样交易性很强的业务中，如果你只是按部就班地走流程，
陷入这种“厄运漏斗”模式，你就会迷失在步骤中，被数字游戏牵着鼻子走。我得联系100个人才能有20个回复，得有10个招聘经理面试才能有4个到现场的。你会被数字所困，然后
失去了人性的一面。你是在寻找那一个人。所以我提醒我的团队，我们是在为这个职位找一个人，不是十个人。所以别纠结于那个“十”，要专注于那个“一”。
这种思维方式的转变真大。就像你说的，不再是漏斗式，顶部需要200人来筛选出底部一个，而是直接锁定全世界最适合这个职位的50个人。
我们只需要这50人中的一个。这感觉容易多了，也更可行。
而且我们希望能与其中其他数十人建立关系。所以当你说这很慢时，我们其实是在播种。我们在播种。我认为另一件经常发生的事情是，
当你陷入这种“厄运漏斗”心态时，另一个常见问题是招聘方法会变得过于千篇一律。而我们非常欢迎量身定制和灵活招聘。这并不是说我们没有类似的阶段来确保一致性，
但关键是，下一场对话是谁，可能会关注什么。我觉得在招聘中有时我们会变得机械化。比如很多公司当招聘量大的时候，他们可能会说：“嘿，我们有这些面试官，他们能做这类面试。”然后就让命运决定，让有空的人来决定下一场对话谁来。
但在招聘量大的时候，他们可能就会说：“嘿，我们有这些面试官，他们能做这类面试。”然后就让命运决定，让有空的人来决定下一场对话谁来。
但聪明的招聘者或招聘经理会想：“哦，他们提到了这个。我们团队中谁对这个感兴趣？我们可以更有针对性地安排，通过多考虑谁和候选人能有更好的交流，来精心策划一场更棒的候选人体验。”
通过多考虑一步，谁和候选人能谈得更好，来提升候选人体验呢？
听到初次接触对整个流程如此重要，以及这既是为了未来播种，也是为即时效果，真有意思。
是的，我觉得我们花了很多精力在现场面试上，这我完全理解，但说实话，最重要的是招聘经理的第一次沟通。所以感觉像是五五开，一半的候选人跟招聘经理谈后应该会来，我们可能低估了它的重要性，因为这是你将一起工作的人。
招聘经理应该来参加面试，我们却低估了它的重要性，因为这是你将要一起工作的人。这位应该是关心候选人、做出招聘决定的人，所以他们应该问最重要的问题，挖掘候选人最重要的动机。
他们应该问最重要的问题，挖掘出候选人最有价值的动机。我觉得有时我们可能只给了30分钟，就像30分钟，但它对后续流程至关重要。
就像只有30分钟，但对后续过程来说，这30分钟感觉至关重要。
尤其是如果我们的理念不是仅仅通过漏斗筛选一群人，而是这人是世界上可能最适合这个职位的50人之一。
招聘经理可能会和候选人见三次面，甚至四次，然后才真正开始整个流程。
Breed在她的文章中描述道，招聘的原子单位是人，而不是职位描述或职位本身。
没错。而且我认为这会让我的团队感到非常沮丧，因为你会问：“流程是什么？”然后我回答：“嗯，这几乎就像一棵决策树，基于对话可能会有多种不同的路线。”但当你不再陷入数字游戏中时，当你的焦点真正在于如何让这个人加入，而不是他们是否适合那个职位时，就不会觉得那么可怕了。
流程可能因对话而走向许多不同方向，所以当你不沉迷于数字游戏，而是专注于如何让这个人加入，而不是他们是否适合那个岗位时，就不那么可怕了。
这个人是适合这个职位的人选吗？
因为这些人在名单上，他们天生就非常受欢迎、很抢手。除了你说的那些温和的暖场引荐之外，还有什么办法能让他们兴奋地聊起来、产生兴趣？
是的，我们试过很多策略来吸引他们参与。其中我特别喜欢的是一起吃饭。和某人共进一餐，是最有人情味、最能拉平地位的事情之一。你懂的，分享一顿饭，
隔着桌子面对面，就是一种解除防备、拉近距离的行为。这非常重要。所以可以是喝杯咖啡，或是一起吃个午饭，不一定要很正式，但我觉得这种人性化的活动，
嗯，我觉得非常重要。所以，我们尽可能围绕饮食来安排。我们也尝试过其他很有用的方法，比如如果他们是那五十人之一，可能有点名气或备受尊敬，
他们往往有专业特长，那就请他们来给团队做个讲座，或者参与一个有趣的副项目。这些人喜欢分享、学习，他们充满好奇心，
这样一来，不仅增强了两队之间的互动质量，也让他们对在这工作有了真实的预览。我们尽量打主场，把他们请到办公室来。
但我们也理解，有些人可能一开始想去咖啡店之类的中立地点。不过，我们还是尽量打主场，因为你有团队的力量。还有，你知道，
我想用一个类比，就像有些人年轻时考虑大学，你走进校园，心里就有种感觉。你很难描述那是什么，
就是那种“哇，这里就像家一样”。我们希望人们走进 Cursor 的办公室时也有这种感觉，那是一个无价的时刻。而且这也是一个决定性的时刻。但有时也可能没感觉，
没感觉的话，早点发现也好。但对很多人来说，确实会有那种感觉，我们喜欢那一刻。
这让我想起 Airbnb 早期的日子。我记得 Joe Gebbia 说过一句话：“只要把他们带进电梯。”因为当时办公室在这栋楼的二楼，你必须坐电梯才能进去，
这就是整个策略，只要把他们带进电梯就行了。
是的，没错。那几乎是成功了一半。
说到一起吃饭和主场优势，我知道这可能是你们在办公室附近开 Cafe Cursor 的原因之一，现在已经开遍全球了。
我想这工作主要由 Ben 负责，现在世界各地都在开这样的咖啡馆。
是的，我觉得这很有意思。显然，它非常聚焦于产品和用户，但他和那个团队做得很好，把那种氛围融入到实体空间中。如果你去过 Cursor 的办公室，
几乎感觉置身于霍格沃茨的图书馆，温暖柔和。而咖啡馆也带来同样的能量。所以我们试图把这种氛围带到世界各地。
嗯，真的遍布全球。
而且办公室还有很多黑板。
确实很多黑板。就像那种让人放松、温暖的感觉，我觉得这体现了我们的中西部风格。有时候我就是这么描述 Cursor 的：非常努力，非常有雄心，
但同时，工作本身就是最好的说明，也很低调。所以，我觉得我们的办公室氛围就很好地激发了这种感觉。
本期节目由 Mercury 赞助播出。这是一家与众不同的银行，深受三十多万创业者的喜爱。现在，还有了 Command。我用 Mercury 已经六年多了，从未想过离开。
Mercury 基本上就是由产品人员而非银行家打造的银行体验。他们让发送发票、转账、为团队设置虚拟卡变得轻而易举，甚至可以说有趣。你的银行有 API、命令行工具，或者支持 AI 的 MCP 服务器吗？我想没有吧。
就在最近，他们推出了 Command，一个直接内置于 Mercury 的对话式界面，相当于你的财务助手。我一直在用 Command 转账、查看消费最多的品类、分析现金流，
就在今天，我还用它查了一下过去从某个赞助商那里赚了多少钱。这真的很方便。
年。我刚刚[音乐]问道，
FDIC承保的银行。银行服务通过Choice Financial Group和Column N/A提供，成员FDIC。
我们已经讨论了如何弄清楚你在寻找什么，弄清楚这些人是谁，如何让他们与你交谈。所以你让他们进入面试阶段。关于如何提高对候选人的信号并确定他们是否合适以及你是否想发出录用通知，你学到了哪些东西？
关于如何提高对候选人的信号并确定他们是否合适以及你是否想发出录用通知，你学到了哪些东西？
>> 是的，其中一些是基础的，嗯，研究表明工作样本是公司成功的最佳预测指标。但大多数公司仍然花费大量时间进行一对一的面对面评估。所以嗯，你知道，我想我们以在某些岗位上进行长时间的现场体验而闻名。嗯，他们在那里做一个项目，并与我们并肩工作。这给了我们非常强烈的信号，也给了候选人巨大的信号。
所以我认为大多数公司在现场面试上犯了错误。他们几乎总是在推销。这就像我们在评估，我们在提取信息。我们没有给候选人太多反馈。我非常相信自我选择的力量。好的自我选择确实需要好的输入和数据。所以我们希望与候选人的体验比大多数公司更像双向的。所以我们真的考虑如何精心打造现场体验，通过他们可能见到的人。我们谈到了这一点。我们确实精心挑选了他们可能在面试中见到的人。我们做了很多工作样本和项目类型的工作来给我们良好的信号，但我们也精心安排了谁迎接他们，谁坐在他们旁边吃午餐。比如我们总是试图把面试安排在用餐时间，比如晚餐、午餐或早餐。一切都精心策划，为他们提供高质量的体验，并让他们获得数据。但同时，我们也从我们认为最能与他建立联系的人那里获取数据。
所以我认为这是大多数公司在现场面试中做错的地方。他们几乎总是在推销。这就像我们在评估，我们在提取信息。我们没有给候选人太多反馈。我非常相信自我选择的力量。好的自我选择确实需要好的输入和数据。所以我们希望与候选人的体验比大多数公司更像双向的。所以我们真的考虑如何精心打造现场体验，通过他们可能见到的人。我们谈到了这一点。我们确实精心挑选了他们可能在面试中见到的人。我们做了很多工作样本和项目类型的工作来给我们良好的信号，但我们也精心安排了谁迎接他们，谁坐在他们旁边吃午餐。比如我们总是试图把面试安排在用餐时间，比如晚餐、午餐或早餐。一切都精心策划，为他们提供高质量的体验，并让他们获得数据。但同时，我们也从我们认为最能与他建立联系的人那里获取数据。
我深信自我选择的力量。而自我选择确实需要良好的输入和数据。所以我们希望与候选人的体验比大多数公司更像双向的。所以我们真的考虑如何精心打造现场体验，通过他们可能见到的人。我们谈到了这一点。我们确实精心挑选了他们可能在面试中见到的人。我们做了很多工作样本和项目类型的工作来给我们良好的信号，但我们也精心安排了谁迎接他们，谁坐在他们旁边吃午餐。比如我们总是试图把面试安排在用餐时间，比如晚餐、午餐或早餐。一切都精心策划，为他们提供高质量的体验，并让他们获得数据。但同时，我们也从我们认为最能与他建立联系的人那里获取数据。
现场体验，通过他们可能见到的人。我们谈到了这一点。我们确实精心挑选了他们可能在面试中见到的人。我们做了很多工作样本和项目类型的工作来给我们良好的信号，但我们也精心安排了谁迎接他们，谁坐在他们旁边吃午餐。比如我们总是试图把面试安排在用餐时间，比如晚餐、午餐或早餐。一切都精心策划，为他们提供高质量的体验，并让他们获得数据。但同时，我们也从我们认为最能与他建立联系的人那里获取数据。
我们也精心安排谁迎接他们，谁坐在他们旁边吃午餐。比如我们总是试图把面试安排在用餐时间，比如晚餐、午餐或早餐。一切都精心策划，为他们提供高质量的体验，并让他们获得数据。但同时，我们也从我们认为最能与他建立联系的人那里获取数据。
数据。但你知道，我们也从我们认为最能与他建立联系的人那里获取数据。
>> 谁负责这种体验？是招聘人员还是招聘经理？
>> 嗯，我想说主要是招聘人员作为四分卫，但他们拉动了很多杠杆。嗯，所以招聘经理可能对其中一些人最有洞察力。我们的招聘协调员非常出色，我想我们可能他们也和我们一起做了很多这样的主持工作。嗯，所以我们的招聘协调员当然做一些日程安排，但他们可能做了更多这种候选人引导工作。所以想象一个候选人跟我们待了一两天，有很多移动的部件，帮助他们从可能做项目的工作站移动到午餐，再回来，帮助他们设置环境。你知道，所以嗯，有很多人参与其中。我们让我们的四分卫，我们的招聘人员作为四分卫，但很多洞察来自招聘经理和协调员的执行。
嗯，他们非常出色，我想我们可能他们也和我们一起做了很多这样的主持工作。嗯，所以我们的招聘协调员当然做一些日程安排，但他们可能做了更多这种候选人引导工作。所以想象一个候选人跟我们待了一两天，有很多移动的部件，帮助他们从可能做项目的工作站移动到午餐，再回来，帮助他们设置环境。你知道，所以嗯，有很多人参与其中。我们让我们的四分卫，我们的招聘人员作为四分卫，但很多洞察来自招聘经理和协调员的执行。
想象一个候选人跟我们待了一两天，有很多移动的部件，帮助他们从可能做项目的工作站移动到午餐，再回来，帮助他们设置环境。你知道，所以嗯，有很多人参与其中。我们让我们的四分卫，我们的招聘人员作为四分卫，但很多洞察来自招聘经理和协调员的执行。
我们让我们的四分卫，我们的招聘人员作为四分卫，但很多洞察来自招聘经理和协调员的执行。
>> 有趣的是，这种世界观——我们与之交谈的每个人都是非常特别的，他们非常罕见，并且是这个职位的最佳人选——对体验和过程的改变有多大。很明显，这种世界观渗透到对旅程中每一个接触点的深入思考，而不是典型的旅程。
很明显，这种世界观渗透到对旅程中每一个接触点的深入思考，而不是典型的旅程。
>> 想象一下，你有团队和员工基础，他们很好地理解这一点，因为他们经历过。所以你超过了公司的临界点，他们有过那种体验。所以他们认识到、承认，现在他们成为下一批人的一部分。多有趣啊？他们有过很棒的体验，现在他们可以帮助为下一批人提供这种体验。所以一旦你度过了最初的困难，你就创造了一个飞轮的机会。
多有趣啊，对吧？他们有过很棒的体验，现在他们可以帮助为下一批人提供这种体验。所以一旦你度过了最初的困难，你就创造了一个飞轮的机会。
>> 我刚刚想起来，实际上，我有一个朋友在Crossover找工作，他说这是他经历过的最好的候选人体验。
>> 那太棒了。
>> 记得那个。
>> [哼声]
>> 所以，所以通过定义，我们考虑了很多关于寻找真正优秀人才的工作。不是所有人都适合我们，无论是他们选择还是我们选择。但每个人都可以离开时成为净推荐者。
而且，按定义来说，他们可是最优秀的一批人。这些推荐者比其他人的分量更重，因为他们有影响力、很出色、而且众所周知很优秀。所以他们也许永远不会回来找我们，但他们可能会告诉别人。
而现在，他们会告诉自己的听众，或者在烧烤聚会上提一嘴，这样就形成了口碑效应，你的吸引力会越来越强，激活他们的难度就会降低。
前提是你做得好。
>> 嗯，完全同意。关于工作试用，我看到迈克尔·特雷尔的一个采访，他说他们曾试图取消它，因为显然这会增加很多负担，有些人不想做这些事，
他说这彻底毁掉了他们的信号，所以他们不得不把它恢复。
>> 是，这确实要投入大量时间，你可以想象。但如果人才是你最看重的事情，那么这么做就是值得的时间投资。在招聘这件事上，我们每个人都有一份责任。
公司里，不是每个人都适合或者擅长做工作试用，但有些人可以。有些人可以负责午餐，有些人可以负责接待，所以有很多不同的方式让人参与进来。
每个人都能发挥作用。但确实，当我们进行那个实验时，因为成本相当高，对候选人要求也高，我们很难对自己的决定有信心。再说一遍，这是建立信心的功能。
所以，我们很高兴把它恢复回来。
>> 这是一个很好的经验教训：如果你不这样做，你就会缺少重要的信号。
>> 可能吧，我也这么认为。我觉得在这行里没有什么绝对的准则，但我认为对许多公司来说，很难想出比并肩完成实际工作更好的方法来获取这些信号。
显然，有些信号是技术性的，但想象一下，在一段时间内你能获得多少关于核心价值观、协作以及其他方面的信号，这些可能比特定的技术技能更重要。
这些信号可能比具体的技术技能更重要。
>> 那对于产品经理、市场或运营这类岗位，你们有什么类似的做法吗？
>> 有的，我们对此有类似的做法。比如销售团队会做一个挑战，他们一起解决一个问题，比如挑战一个难缠的客户之类的。
这通常是与招聘经理一对一的。产品团队也会做类似的项目协作。所以，我们有一些这样的变体，根据职能和具体角色进行了调整。
我们尽量保持一致性，因为不同职能差异很大。
>> 对工作试用的一个典型批评是，你是在为公司免费工作，就像我会为你免费解决问题。
>> 是的。
>> 他们解决问题的速度如何，比如工程或产品经理？
>> 他们可以从一系列问题中选择，所以我们觉得他们有一定方向和自由。同时我们也非常灵活，会根据他们的背景、时间和可用性来调整范围。
所以我们会尽量灵活和理解。有时我们也会用周六时间，因为我们知道在正常工作日抽时间很难，我们完全理解。这是个不小的要求，但值得。
传统工作日，我们完全理解。这确实是个很大的承诺，但我们认为值得，我们也愿意安排在他们方便的时间。
但当他们准备好时，我们会迅速行动。我们会弥补那段时间。比如我们初次沟通时，你说你两天后有空，我会说打开你的日历，我一看日历，好的，一个小时后就能安排他们交谈。
所以你要在他们准备好后迅速行动，抓住机会。不能给他们留下犹豫的空间。所以我们一旦决定就会快速推进，但我们会……
可能需要很长时间才能达到那个时刻。
进一步推进流程，你决定向某人发出录用通知的时刻是怎样的？具体有没有你特别看重的东西？或者流程是怎样的，比如有个招聘委员会会议之类的？
委员会会议还是别的什么？
是的，我们会尽快作为团队进行复盘。每个职能部门的招聘流程略有不同，但我们没有招聘委员会，而是由招聘经理主导，他们从团队那里获得大量意见。
记住，招聘经理的角色不是民主投票。招聘经理负责让团队提供正确的信息，以帮助他们做出最佳决策。
就是雇或不雇的决定。所以我们尽量这样去框定，确保获得真正可靠的信号。我们会尽快行动，通常当天或第二天就进行复盘。
然后这个决定会提交给创始人审批。
太棒了。好的，然后进入录用阶段。这里有很多事情要处理，但其中之一是如今有很多大额录用通知。假设你向顶尖50人之一发出了录用通知，他们说：
“好吧，但我还收到了Anthropic的一个巨额offer。”
嗯哼。
你怎么处理这种情况？而且这是让你很沮丧，还是觉得“哇，这更说明这个人很厉害”？
我觉得两种情况都可能，都有发生的可能。我认为目标不是在最后时刻去推销。我们在整个过程中都在推销。所以想想招聘的技巧，
招聘的技巧就在于一开始就要清楚了解这个人的动机，他们可能因为什么而跳槽，追求什么。然后确保整个体验都契合这些点。所以最后是水到渠成，而不是才开始。
对吧？感觉几乎是自然而然的结果。就像“哦，这几乎是下一步了，是的，这是我们讨论过的offer。”
所以，我们不是开始倒计时或开始谈条件，而是回到最初他们的动机。我们会考虑如何在内在方面进行区分，比如职位、团队或共事的人。
我们真正专注于内在因素，而不是外在的金钱等，这很难做到，因为竞争对手的薪水和奖金可能很高。
但我们真的专注于那些想要留在这里的人。通常当人们考虑工作时，他们会从一些条件出发，而我们可能帮助他们发现其他方面。
过程中我们可能会发现最终这并不合适，那也没关系，我们很乐意放弃。但通常是通过这个过程帮助他们发现这里可能是合适的地方。
通过这个旅程找到合适的地方。
有多少人接受的工作不是薪酬最高的？这种情况常见还是少见？
我认为你试图降低薪酬作为人们来或不来的原因的影响。这通常意味着你不是薪酬最高的那家。我们可能都和一些在职业生涯中只追求最高薪酬的人聊过。
他们可能追过最高薪酬，但半年后你会意识到，这只是你新的薪酬水平，但你对同事或工作并不感到兴奋。
所以我们试图减少这种情况，但我觉得这经常发生。有时我们可能是薪酬最高的，但他们还是去了别处，如果那更适合他们，那也行。这听起来可能有点乐观，但我坚信，在正确的时间，有合适的人加入合适的公司。
如果他们最终发现我们不合适，那对他们来说是正确的决定。作为招聘人员，如果他们没有找到合适的岗位，我六个月后还得重新招聘，我不想重复工作。我们宁愿现在就弄清楚，并更开放地交谈。
如果对他们来说这是正确的选择，作为招聘人员，如果他们不合适，我六个月后还得重新招聘。我不想重复工作。还是现在就搞清楚，并更开放地交流吧。
你应该创建一个能帮你判断哪个公司当前最适合你的智能助手，这听起来确实很有价值。
那会非常有趣。
我听说Anthropic有个做法，与特斯拉类似，他们不让你讨价还价，直接给出offer。你觉得这是不是只有Anthropic才能这么做？
是因为他们作为Anthropic才有底气，还是你也会考虑这种做法？
我确实考虑过。我看到不同公司曾采用不同策略。我欣赏的是他们做出决定并坚持到底，有承诺。但每个公司情况不同，我认为方法各异。我尊重这种风格，但对我们来说可能并不适用。
每个公司都不一样，我尊重这种模式，但对我们而言可能并不合适。
从候选人角度看，他们在接受offer时常犯哪些错误，会自己坑自己？
我给候选人的一般建议是，当你考虑薪酬并谈判时，必须有逻辑依据。如果你要求某种薪酬或其他条件，要讲清楚背后的道理，这样有助于对方理解并传达给决策者。
你提出的要求要基于清晰逻辑，这样别人容易理解也容易转达给其他决策者。
相反，我见过一些候选人东拉西扯，前后不一，要求不断叠加，而不是一开始就明确提出四点重点并保持一致。当然并非所有条件刚开始就能提全，但这样显得更有逻辑，公司也更好应对。
比如一开始就说‘这四点对我很重要’，并保持清晰一致，这样逻辑清晰，公司也容易配合。
这样公司才能更好地与你沟通协商。
而不是随便找理由多要钱。
对。公司通常明白自己并非候选人的首选，所以我们得靠诚意打动他们，而不是靠买断。
我们不是要买断对方，而是想赢得人心。
现在的薪酬水平有多惊人？你应该见过很多吧。
是的，真实情况甚至更夸张，或者说更高。许多AI公司在思考，这种情况会如何发展，最终会走向何方？没人知道。但关键的衡量单位是最固定和有限的资源——时间。获得模型、人才，是争分夺秒的竞赛，这是最重要也最宝贵的。
最重要的衡量单位是时间，这是最固定且有限的。获取模型与人才是抢时间的竞赛，时间是最重要、最宝贵的资源。
显然有些公司有更多资金和资源，但在这个市场中，时间是我们最固定且宝贵的资产。
回到AI研究员这股热潮，这些人以前默默无闻地搞模型，没人关注，现在却成了抢手货。
我记得曾在Facebook帮助组建研究团队，那时他们甚至不招博士或高学历人才，那是2010年左右。
我见过一批学者，他们越来越沮丧，因为研究成果无法走出学术界。所以他们现在迎来高光时刻，我为他们高兴。
他们获得关注是我的乐见，他们在技术创新的底层默默贡献了几十年，现在该他们发光了，这是实至名归。
沿着这个思路，结束我们的‘欢乐漏斗’而非‘沮丧漏斗’。
嗯，我喜欢这个说法。
我从你的候选人那里听说，他们评价你和你团队把候选人成功转化并接受offer的能力非常出色。你们是用什么方法帮助那些犹豫不定的人做出最终决定的？
那些还在观望的人？
对，我觉得有几个方面。首先，我想再强调一下，整个流程其实一直在做说服工作。比如安排他们见什么人，了解他们的动机，我们会一直消除他们的顾虑。
这是第一点。第二点是，说服候选人是个团队工作。所以，当我们遇到一个非常优秀、高规格的候选人时，我们会每天开个短会，讨论怎么让他们点头。
这个会可能只有十分钟，但重点不是时间长短，而是我们每天集中精力，共同推进这件事。参与者包括招聘经理、招聘人员，可能还有以前的同事。
因为影响候选人决定的人很多，我们很用心地让他们感觉到被关心、有归属感，觉得来这里是对的，并且及时跟进。第三点是，
我们努力让招聘过程非常个性化。就在这周，大概两天前，我看到了一个例子，我们会在内部分享这些故事，因为这能塑造招聘文化，我们也会把故事传回公司。
我们正在争取一个纽约的候选人，在了解过程中发现，他上过艺术高中，还受过古典小提琴训练。而我们团队对弦乐器特别着迷。
于是，我们在纽约找到了一家特色乐器店，买了一把独特的土耳其吉他，介于吉他和提琴之间的那种。他们约了对方吃晚餐，
在给offer的时候，把这个礼物送给了他。那礼物也就几百美元，并不贵，特别是相对于offer的价值和我们预期他能带来的影响来说，
关键在于心意和那份特别的感动，以及那个专属的瞬间，这让他们印象深刻。当候选人回想最好的招聘体验时，
他们会觉得：哇，这简直是为我量身定做的，对我来说独一无二。
我知道你们还为每个候选人建了Slack频道。
对，每个候选人都有。你说的那个短会，有时候也讨论策略和进展，这个集结动员的效果在最后阶段也是一样的，每个候选人都有专属频道。
这么多事情都归结于对每个候选人的用心，不是把他们看作漏斗，而是把每个人当作最小单位。在过程中我们能做些什么让他们
感到兴奋，并且判断他们是否合适呢？
在那种大规模招聘流程中很难做到。如果每个职位都看一百个候选人，那确实无法规模化。但如果缩小范围，只针对少数
你花时间培养过的人，因为人数少，流程就更快了。所以你在整个漏斗上花费的时间差不多，只是用在了不同的环节。
你只是把时间花在了不同的地方。
真有意思，这是完全不同的方法。我从没听说过有人这样招人。
对，我在Growth by Design的时候就有这样的想法，我们认为应该有另一种方式来招聘。我们看过很多公司，也和他们合作过，
感觉这些公司正处于技术革命的最前沿，可能是几千年一遇的激动人心的时刻，但他们招聘却还停留在网页浏览器的老套方式。我们想，如果一家公司
愿意投入时间和精力形成这种集体力量，他们在人才竞争上就能获得压倒性优势。回顾公司的发展，有些成为了标志性品牌，有些却默默无闻，
关键往往不在于谁先来、谁最快、谁的创意最早，而在于执行。执行又取决于在合适的时机有合适的人。当公司明白这一点，他们就会觉得，
这才是最重要的事情，我们应该认真对待。所以当我们遇到Cursor时，我们就想：这应该会很有趣。
Cursor其实正是你所说的绝佳例子，因为在Cursor的整个发展历程中，总有人质疑他们怎么活下去，说这些模型公司在做这些产品，还有那些IDE...
人们似乎正在远离IDE，但看着Cursor一路执行并领先于这些变化，真是令人惊叹。每当有人怀疑这里还有没有机会，它总能持续增长，表现得非常出色。
我的意思是，就在不久之前，还只是自动补全标签，现在已经完全是云端代理了，而且...但请记住，时间跨度很短，你知道的，它...
【笑声】
这种紧凑的演化简直太疯狂了。
有一次我到办公室，看到一个标签按钮，现在那玩意已经不算什么了。
是的，现在它只是可爱而已。没错，现在它只能放在架子上。
然后谈谈你同事让我问的问题：和一支真正相信招聘是最重要的事情的团队合作，感觉如何？
这是一种恩赐，有时也极其令人沮丧。恩赐的部分在于，想象一下他们有多在乎，比如说服创始人去参加个对话或做任何招聘相关的事，这根本不是问题。
在这里，我们和那些需要你去推动的公司合作过。所以这确实是一份礼物。挑战在于，他们非常投入，你懂的，他们...
他们理解。Cursor团队前80个人都是自己招的，他们知道怎么做，也知道这有多难，这很好，但他们也热爱这个，他们投入其中，想要去做。
所以他们在这方面没有任何自我，不纠结谁拥有什么部分，这是全员投入。有时候这可能会让人困惑，比如谁在做什么，事情发生后你才知道...
有些事发生后才发觉，但你知道吗，我愿意每天都接受这种状况。这绝对是净正面，但你知道，总有代价要和这种优势平衡。
真有趣。就像首席产品官常常会因为创始人总是插手而感到沮丧。
是的，但他们在乎。你知道，我愿意接受这份努力和关心，连同这个代价一起。
然后你的一个激进观点是，招聘团队应该是公司里薪酬最高的团队。
是的，其中之一。如果不是最高的，我是说，如果你考虑他们带来的影响，你会觉得，我感觉现在对于真正有战略眼光的招聘者存在供需危机，因为...
我们长期把招聘变成了一种交易性质的工作。所以我认为，能在这个水平和这种方式下运作的招聘者供应量很小。因此，就像任何劳动力市场一样，这是...
劳动力成本的问题，而这种人才非常稀缺。所以，我们认为他们有巨大的影响力，但这真的是一种罕见的技能。
有个我忘了问的问题：我们经常谈论人才密度，它有多少是关于个人本身，又有多少是围绕他们组建的团队？
我觉得公司往往会过分关注个人。除非他们是单人团队，否则，如果你想想优秀的领导者和经理，他们实际上是很出色的拼图构建者。
他们会考虑组建互补的团队，然后帮助这些团队脱颖而出。所以，人才密度不是指单个成员，除非分子和分母都是1。你知道，但事实并非如此。
通常情况下，个人是分子，团队人数是分母，所以人才密度实际上是关于个人和人类的集体属性。但我们常常因为一次只招一个人，而过度聚焦于那个特定的...
“十倍速”员工，你知道吗？实际上，我更倾向于考虑团队的指数级增长，而不是个人。我不认为在一个糟糕的团队里能有一个十倍速的人，这根本不可能。你知道...
我觉得，我以前在上一家公司时曾想，如果我们没有优秀的客户，我们就无法成为优秀的客户服务提供商，我们无法获得...那里有一个标杆。同样地...
即使是优秀的人才，如果不在强大且支持性的团队中，也会受到限制。
>> 这说得通。好，我要问你一系列随机问题。我想听众听到这些后会说，我需要亚当，我们需要帮助时。但他们可能得不到帮助，
因为你知道，你有工作。所以，我要在这次访谈中尽可能地挖掘你的见解。当你是一个早期阶段的公司，考虑招聘，并建立你的招聘方法时，最常见的方式有哪些？
早期阶段的公司和创始人在早期团队和招聘上犯的主要错误是什么？
>> 是的，我认为他们试图做的是寻找一个“银弹”式的招聘，即第一次就聘请一位人才负责人，但他们把两个相互竞争的技能集合并到一个角色中。所以，当你作为创始人，准备好招聘你的
第一位招聘人员时，你可能已经落后于招聘进度了。这里有个问题需要解决。你落后了，所以可能积压了一些职位空缺，比如5个、10个、15个。但你在这一阶段招聘，也是因为你希望他们能建立一套
体系。就像我们这样的公司，他们可能会想：“哇，我想建立像亚当所描述的那样。”所以，你试图招聘一个能够放入正确组件来帮助扩展的人。然而，
这些都是相互竞争的利益。因为一个新员工想要加入，他们想证明自己，他们想完成招聘，但他们可能不会建立体系，或者他们建立了体系，但不会
进行招聘，然后你就无法入睡了。所以，他们试图将这些压缩到一个角色中，但这通常是个错误。我们建议解耦这些事项。这意味着你可能仍然想依赖
一个人，但你能在其他方面得到帮助吗？比如，我会聘请一个能建立正确体系的人，但我会让他们与一个临时招聘人员或其他人员合作，以取得一些短期进展，
而他们则通过这些他们帮助协调的职位来教会公司如何做这件事；或者反过来。我可能会带一个人来帮助我们建立正确的基础，就像我们在GBD做的那样，
然后他们可以聘请一位非常强大的独立招聘人员来执行具体工作。
>> 太棒了。这完全说得通。当你寻找第一位招聘人员时，你觉得还有什么重要的特质需要考虑？我知道这取决于他们属于这两个类别中的哪一个，但
还有其他建议吗？
>> 是的，我认为第一点是他们要有好奇心并且以业务为导向。他们是团队中早期的成员，必须非常好奇并理解业务如何运作，以及每次招聘将如何
改变业务的发展斜率。
>> 嗯。
>> 嗯，所以
>> 你知道，通常这意味着他们有很多有趣的特质，这些特质会以多种方式显现出来，比如好奇心。但我觉得这是最重要的。第二点，有时我会认为这两者有时会被颠倒，
第二点是积极主动，你知道，有人能理解这种辛劳和节奏，并愿意接受。这并不意味着他们必须年轻，或者其他什么，只是他们
喜欢在超负荷的边缘工作。所以我经常考虑我的团队，我们希望水位正好保持在这个位置。这样你就能呼吸，但你知道，如果你见过任何类型的招聘人员，
招聘人员在工作量达到90%到110%时表现最佳，超出这个范围就很糟糕。如果他们的任务量只有一半，他们就会无所事事。或者如果工作量过高，他们也会不知所措。但是，
他们在这种中间地带表现得很好，即处于肾上腺素激增的忙碌边缘。你要找的就是这样的人。
>> 哦，天哪。关于这一点，我听到很多人说你的团队有大量追随者。其他公司的人才负责人决定加入你的团队担任独立贡献者。你学到了哪些经验？
关于打造一支卓越的团队，并让人才长期为你效力，你有什么心得吗？
我学到的一点是，每个地方，我的团队形态都各不相同，因为各家公司对招聘和产品的思路不一样。比如，在Cursive，就需要一支不同类型的团队，它要求...
...招聘人员有那样的水平，熟悉高层招聘的套路，不会陷入单纯的漏斗数据游戏。他们得有自信，还得有人脉网络可挖。
他们会有人脉可挖。我们也常聊起招聘经理和其他人脉，但资深招聘人员其实也有自己的圈子。比如，你身边总有那么几个你信得过的招聘顾问，你可能会去向他们请教。
你往往会去找他们出出主意。所以我们也想把这些人招揽进来，因为他们在人脉挖掘上的影响力不亚于技术负责人。于是我就想，我到底希望团队成员具备哪些特质呢？
我总结出三个特质。第一，我希望他们人品出色，专业能力也出色，这两者不可偏废。毕竟，工作占据了我们一周大部分清醒时间，我们理应和优秀的人共事。
我们都应该“自私”一点，只想和优秀的人合作。第二，我希望他们有点不服输的劲头，心里憋着一股证明自己的劲儿，热爱自己的手艺，有内在动力去追求卓越。这种特质可能表现形式多样，我会去深入了解。
对，就是那种追求卓越的内在驱动力。它会以各种方式表现出来，我会去探寻。第三点，我希望他们能以团队为先，而不是个人。这一点对我现在带的团队来说至关重要。
我现在的团队成员本可以在很多地方负责招聘，但他们明白，没人真正渴望爬到中层管理的位置，我们往往是不知不觉就到了那里。但他们真正看重的是：
热爱招聘这门手艺，喜欢挑战，渴望学习，希望和优秀的人共事。所以，当我向人脉打听时，我会说：“嘿，Lenny，你认识哪三个人既人品好，又是优秀的招聘人员？”
他们可能天生有那股冲劲，或者带着点不服输，而且把团队利益放在个人之上。你可能会说：“哦，那你该去找Janet聊聊。”你看，你总能想到这样的人。
所以，我们确实在努力打造一支这样的队伍，我对已经聚到一起的这些伙伴感到非常兴奋。
嗯，当我说‘等等，我想为Adam工作，这听起来真棒’时，这是个好兆头。
我努力保持一种平衡，因为招聘有时是关于激励团队的，但它本质上是一项运营工作。
深入其中，和他们一起做，但有时也要跳出来，描绘更大的图景。
太棒了，Adam，我们涵盖了很多内容，走完了整个流程还更多。在我们进入激动人心的快速问答环节之前，你还有什么想分享的，或者想对听众说的，或者想特别强调的要点吗？
有什么你想特别强调的要点吗？
我的意思是，有件事我们没聊到，而且我觉得越来越常见，就是接受offer后又反悔的情况。所以我觉得很多公司在候选人接受offer后，通常会有一段时间的间隔。
对于职位越高的人，这段时间通常超过两周。我们考虑在offer接受后进行第二个步骤，因为在招聘中，我们是那种‘按钮座位’业务，也就是说，候选人接受offer后，我们就像没事了一样继续下一个。但在接受offer和入职之间，我们该做些什么呢？有两个关键部分。
这是一个很大的窗口期，有人接受了offer，我们却转去忙别的了。但在接受offer和入职之间，我们该做什么？有两个关键点：一是确保他们真的来，二是进行一些入职前的准备，通过保持联系帮助他们快速上手。
第二是做一些入职前的准备，通过保持联系帮助他们快速上手。所以，我们会和其他已经接受offer的人一起吃饭，试图在他们周围创建一个社区。我们还会给他们寄一台Cursor笔记本电脑，感觉就像他们已经加入了。
这有点像一种‘你已加入’的先入为主的姿态。我们会做这些晚宴，这些触点，一是确保交付，二是让他们开始感到兴奋，开始想象未来会是什么样子。
直观地想象未来的工作会是什么样子。
哇，经历了整个流程，拿到offer，发出offer，对方接受，我们却失去了他，这太残酷了。你说这是一种趋势，我猜是因为市场竞争激烈，他们会收到更好的offer，一些他们意想不到的offer。
更好的offer，他们没料到的offer。
>> 对。
>> 是的。我总觉得还有很多没聊到的。你在招聘领域还注意到其他趋势或变化吗？
>> 我觉得另一个趋势是“人才工程师”的崛起。你可能也看到了，就是招聘团队里的一种角色，可能是前工程师。
他们负责搭建工具之类的。我的温和观点（不是激进观点）是，每个招聘人员都应该成为人才工程师。现在招聘人员手头能用的工具，比如在Cursor或其他工具里自己构建的东西，真的很了不起。
这真的很惊人。在我之前待过的公司，我们常常得求着工程师给我们建工具或功能。现在这些我们自己就能做，就在我们团队手里。所以我希望未来我的招聘团队能觉得自己就是人才工程师。
而不是依赖团队里其他人帮忙搭工具，你懂吧。
>> 当然，完全同意。有意思的是，现在有“市场工程师”之类的，每个职能都会有自己的“工程师”版本。
>> 是的。
>> 随时间推移。好了，Adam，我们到了激动人心的快速问答环节。我有五个问题，你准备好了吗？
>> 准备好了。
>> 好的。你经常推荐给别人哪两三本书？
>> 这有点书呆子气。有两本。一本是我本科时读的，一直印象深刻，就是丹尼尔·戈尔曼的《情商》。你知道的，情商的重要性日益凸显。
在现在这个AI时代，情商比以往任何时候都重要。这本书当时对我影响很大，现在我觉得它仍然非常重要。
>> 另一本我想推荐给创始人的是埃拉德·吉尔的《高速增长手册》。我喜欢那种可以随手翻到一章就能找到答案的书，而不是必须从头线性读完。
所以我觉得它是一本很好的参考指南，涵盖了各种问题。基本上，创业公司的核心原则和组成部分是相同的，即使这本书是几年前出版的，核心原则依然适用。
>> 所以我喜欢《高速增长手册》。
>> 来自Stripe出版社的书。我想你应该也读过克莱尔·休斯·约翰逊的《规模化团队》，感觉很适合你。
>> 是的，我很喜欢她。
>> 嗯，也是Stripe出版社的。太棒了。我也喜欢Elad那本书，不管多少年后它依然有用。
>> 太棒了。
>> 是的。
>> 你最近喜欢看的电影或剧集是什么？
>> 我几年没看电影了。我的生活都是碎片化的，二十分钟一截。不过我一直在看一部剧叫《The Pit》。我来自西宾夕法尼亚，匹兹堡那边，这部剧不仅制作精良，而且让我感觉生活没那么慌乱。
除了制作精良，它还让我觉得生活从容了一些。
>> [笑声]
说实话，能让我感觉生活没那么混乱的唯一办法，就是在急诊室待上一个小时。你知道，那里的人经历着什么。我经常跟我团队说，让大家明白事情的轻重缓急。我就说，
“嘿，大家想想，我们很幸运能在这家很棒的公司做产品，但我们做的决定并不会让人生死攸关。可在急诊室，那真是人命关天，你知道吗？所以这能让我们摆正心态。
还有第三点，我觉得他们抓住了那个地区的精髓，这也是我的核心，就是西宾夕法尼亚蓝领精神。我觉得他们在这方面做得特别好。所以，我
有时候在飞机上，我会看那个剧。
我喜欢这一点，对大多数人来说，那个剧压力很大，但对你来说却很平静，因为（笑声）它比你自己的生活压力小多了。
就是事物的相对性，挺有帮助的。
那你有没有看过《熊家餐馆》？我觉得那会是另一个例子。
看过，我觉得如果我是芝加哥人，可能感触更深。不过我也确实看了。
天哪，好吧。还有几个问题。除了Cursor，你有没有最近发现很喜欢的产品？
有，我觉得一个是比较新的，还有一个不是。我是Granola的超级粉丝，很早就开始用了，我喜欢他们不断创新，而且产品决策做得好，用起来也简单。
他们对于反馈也处理得很好，你给他们提意见，他们反应特别快。另外一个我经常用的是Whisper，WhisperFlow。就是想快速给团队留个言。我打字表达想法不如说话方便。
所以Whisper真的很好用，随时随地可以给团队留言。
Adam，你听听这个，你可能不知道。
我真不知道。
订阅我通讯稿的人，不光Cursor，连Granola和WhisperFlow都能免费一年。
还有其他30个很棒的产品，比如Replit、Google和Lovable，多得不得了。所以如果你喜欢这些东西，
（笑声）
ladiesproducthunt.com。
那根本不是什么网站，我是真不知道。
我们就是所有最好的产品都免费一年，包括Cursor，就是这样。ladiesproducthunt.com。
（笑声）
好的，还有两个问题。你有没有在工作和生活中经常引用的人生格言？
有，我觉得有三句话我经常想起，也试图教给孩子们。第一句是努力工作，努力的价值怎么强调都不过分，这是我从小在那种环境里学到的。
第二句是做好工作，别把这两者混淆了。第三句是与人为善。我觉得我一直努力去做这一点，也许这也是我能帮助建立这个团队的部分原因，我真的只是试着
乐于助人。如果你去问那些创始人，无论是谁，我都会回复他们的邮件，我也会跟他们进行十分钟的通话。我希望人们来找我寻求帮助和建议，而且是对的人来找我。所以
现在开始收获回报了，有人愿意加入我们的团队，所以这三件事我一直努力践行。
这真是一套很棒的人生准则，显然对你的成功很有帮助。我要全部偷师。这些真的很好，就像是一个很好的三脚架。你提到了当爸爸的事，最后一个问题。
人们说你是讲恰到好处的爸爸笑话的专家。我不打算让你讲笑话，除非你想讲，但更想问问你在养育孩子方面学到些什么，因为我也是一位爸爸，孩子三岁了。关于培养优秀的孩子，你有何心得？
比如，你学到了哪些培养优秀孩子的经验？
这很让人谦卑。你知道，他们会以你意想不到的方式挑战你。有时候他们就像你的小小镜子。所以这就像一种反馈机制。而且说实话，这真的是一种巨大的快乐。
我很幸运有一位了不起的妻子和伴侣，她时常，大多数时候，承担着不公平的重担。但是，这绝对是我最大的快乐。
这总结得真好。确实就是这种感觉。有时很有挑战性，但却是最大的快乐。
但想想你的职业生涯，当你回顾那些最享受的时刻，你其实是有点冒险的。你被抛到意料之外、措手不及的境地。
然后你设法解决了问题。当时可能是一连串的起起落落，叠加的S曲线，但后来回顾时，你会觉得“哇，那是我职业生涯的高光时刻之一。”但你当时其实是在冒险。
莫莉·格雷厄姆来过播客，还写过几篇通讯客座文章，她提出了一个概念叫J曲线，说最好的角色是当你加入时，先沉下去，在一段时间内表现糟糕，
然后回升，那就是你最棒的经历。
莫莉确实很有见解。
她非常了不起。她现在正在写一篇新的客座文章，可能等节目播出时就会发表了。
太棒了。
最后再问两个问题，亚当。你有什么想推广的？想让人们关注什么？听众如何能帮到你？
我觉得这两件事是一回事。我想推广的是，希望大家能试试Cursor。我认为我们即将推出的东西非常令人兴奋，我们为此感到自豪。还有一些
在筹备中。我并不是很常在线上露面。我可能在LinkedIn上有点活跃，但我真的尽量让我的工作和团队来代表我们。但我总是愿意帮忙，回到最后一点，所以
我确实从帮助别人中获得纯粹的活力和快乐。所以，我知道在某个时刻，这会以某种形式回报我。我不期待回报，但那是我动力的来源。
帮Cursor多说两句。不仅设计和体验很棒，对很多人来说，最好的功能就是可以非常轻松地在不同模型间切换。所以，不用非得用Codex或Claude code，
用Cursor，然后当新的Opus或GPT出现时，你可以马上切换并试用，而不是更换产品。
是的，以前模型每三四个月才出一个，现在间隔缩短到几天。我认识的那些喜欢做产品的人，希望随时使用最好的工具。所以，
我们的智能体允许你选择合适的模型。我认为对许多公司来说，成本也是一个重要的考虑因素。因此，优化就是使用合适的模型做合适的任务。这就是
Cursor最擅长的领域。
是啊，而且你们现在还在构建前沿模型，放在SpaceX的数据中心上，对Cursor来说简直是全新的世界。
我是说，能在全球最大的数据中心上训练模型，真是解锁了我们的能力。太棒了，简直不可思议。
活在这个时代真好。
真是疯狂。
Adam，非常感谢你来到我们节目。
谢谢邀请。
大家再见，非常感谢收听。如果你觉得这期内容有用，可以在Apple Podcast、Spotify或你喜欢的播客应用上订阅我们的节目。也请考虑给我们评分或留言评论，这真的能帮到其他听众发现我们的播客。
你可以在lennyspodcast.com找到所有往期节目或了解更多信息。音乐响起，我们下期再见。